chez les légumes ça ne s'invente pas la
famille propose des croisières sur la
Seine à bord de konkiki qui peut
embarquer jusqu'à quatre personnes il
est possible de découvrir le fleuve au
travers de sa faune et de sa flore mais
aussi le patrimoine culturel et
historique des communes traversées
aujourd'hui c'est à Juziers que nous
embarquons
[Musique]
et à la barre c'est Manuel l'écluse
manuel pourquoi avoir eu envie de
proposer ces balades aux yvelinois et
bien parce que moi ça fait une dizaine
d'années que j'habite ici en bord de
Seine on le faisait avec ma femme mes
enfants en le proposait à nos amis le
week-end à nos familles et on trouve le
coin tellement beau on aime le bateau
donc j'ai voulu créer quelque chose à
côté de mon activité principale pour
faire découvrir cette superbe région
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous proposez comme balade
là aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir découvrir alors aujourd'hui je
vais vous proposer moi directement le ce
qu'on appelle le pack découvertes c'est
une mise en bouche on va dire mais une
belle mise en bouche où on va faire une
balade d'environ une heure donc on va
sortir du petit bras pour prendre le
grand bras et faire le tour de l'île
verte qui est bien plus grande que ce
que l'on imagine
[Musique]
j'ai mis tout le monde à contribution
mon épouse mon fils et ma fille on se
répartit les rôles quand j'ai des packs
apéro ou des packs c'est mon épouse qui
se voilà qui leur prépare le petit
grignotage ou les bonnes salades si pour
le pique-nique les bons desserts etc
tout le monde joue le jeu
[Musique]
terrain de jeu incroyable la scène
effectivement que ce soit ici sur ce
petit bassin d'eau là dans un petit
passage devant melon et le paysage il
est il est varié
[Musique]
et donc vous avez pu emmener qu'est-ce
qu'ils apprécient particulièrement et
qu'est-ce qu'il vous faut comme retour
bah ils sont ils sont émerveillés ils
sont émerveillés par par les lieux parce
qu'on y voit et ça tombe bien que vous
posez la question ici Grégory parce que
quand on propose le petit arrêt apéritif
par exemple
selon le soleil où il est on vient se
qu'on vient se mettre là et ils ont
l'impression d'être en vacances
pour une balade comptée de 15 à 300
euros selon la formule vous pouvez
réserver par téléphone ou par mail moi
je vous laisse et je vais profiter du
paysage